[Musique]
Hélène buzetti Jonathan Trudeau à la
castonguer bonsoir bonsoir on va parler
de cette guerre que même pierre
poillievre a CIBC et de Twitter et de
tout le reste on va vous exposer ça
point par point mais d'abord
samedi soir vous y étiez Jonathan je
crois sauf erreur à cette fête en
l'honneur de des 20 ans d'accession au
pouvoir de Jean Charest donc le ministre
Bachant entre autres bon je le dis on le
voit il y avait pas mal de monde et puis
monsieur charrette nous a dit tout à
l'heure ça a été presque la plus belle
journée de ma vie les politiciens les
élus cherchent la reconnaissance d'une
évidence et je pense qu'il y a eu un peu
de reconnaissance dans cette soirée là
il a senti comme ça
absolument j'étais là parce que j'ai
travaillé pour ce gouvernement là moi de
2004 à 2010 notamment deux années
passées comme conseiller ou
communication au cabinet de Monsieur
Charest donc si vous cherchez quelqu'un
qui va tout dépeindre en noir le bilan
de ce gouvernement là c'est pas moi-même
je peux lui reconnaître certains temps
mais il risque que ça faisait du bien à
la grande famille libérale justement
libérale faut dire qu'il y a bien des
gens dont je suis qui n'ont plus
d'étiquette politique depuis ce temps-là
mettez des gens qui ont travaillé
ensemble cette époque-là de de se
retrouver de se rappeler des bons
souvenirs ça faisait du bien et pour
monsieur charé je pense que il y a toute
une démarche que je ramènerai même à
l'époque où il a décidé de faire le saut
avec avec le Parti conservateur de ce de
se présenter à la chefferie du Parti
conservateur pour compte pierre pour
pour lièvre de
rétablir un peu si on veut son image
publique de ne pas uniquement le tablé
sur bon des perceptions négatives que
certains peuvent avoir et pour lui ce
20e anniversaire là se rappeler le bilan
positif qu'il fait l'affection aussi que
similaires que c'est les élus avaient
pour lui je pense que il y a
effectivement là quelque chose qui lui
fait le plus grand des biens une
tentative de recadrer si on veut son
action dans la grande Histoire politique
et Alec également de
passer à autre chose après il faut quand
même le dire une gifle politique contre
Pierre poilliev qui a été l'automne
dernier assez raide et de ne et sa
victoire contre le PAC arrive tout au
même moment là il veut donc qu'on se
souvienne de lui pour d'autres choses
ouais dans votre entrevue Patrice Jean
Charest a un certain moment la vérité
c'est droit la vérité reprend ses droits
un certain moment le problème c'est que
la politique et la vérité ça fait pas
toujours bon ménage la perception est
souvent plus importante que la vérité et
Jonathan sait quelque chose il y a fait
des communications en communication on
dit même si c'est vrai monsieur le
ministre même si CV monsieur le Premier
ministre si les gens ne perçoivent pas
comme ça c'est donc pas la réalité et la
vérité et la perception prime et la
perception au Québec depuis un bon
moment c'est que j'ai enchaîné à diriger
un gouvernement corrompu essouffler avec
un paquet de problèmes éthiques et puis
c'est ça que beaucoup de gens se
remémorent du gouvernement là même s'il
a fait autre chose et vous l'avez libéré
dans votre vie que ce soit la bourse du
carbone font des générations il y a
énormément de choses qui ont été faites
le Conseil de la fédération subsiste à
ce jour est une invention de Jean
Charest mais la perception publique elle
est négative autour de Jean-Charles et
oui il y avait peut-être un peu de
volonté de rétablir sa réputation on est
en train dans la course à la direction
du parti conservateurs certainement que
lui pacte le jugement oublie pas qu'il
sévèrement blanc mais lui fait plaisir
pour ça et ça devait lui faire du bien
de se rappeler avec son entourage en
fait semaine qu'effectivement il y a pas
que de mauvaises choses qui sont sortis
de ses 10 ans au pouvoir ça fait mal à
un politicien quand la perception qu'on
retient n'est pas celle qu'on souhaite
et on sent que j'en charrette encore
blessé par ça bien des années plus tard
ah c'est clair il aime et d'ailleurs
elle est en justice parce qu'il dit ça
peut sembler facile pour les gens mais
il faut quand même aller devant une cour
et tout ça la dernière victoire contre
l'UPAC c'est un peu un bombe sur une
blessure qui est vive là Hélène oui en
fait ça me fascine le nombre de
similitudes qu'il y a avec Bryan
malronné qui a suivi un peu le même
cheminement monsieur malronnier qui a
été premier ministre du Canada et qui
lorsqu'il est parti bon sont partis
s'était fait complètement éradiquer la
carte électorale monsieur malronné était
parti dans un atmosphère un peu
obligation de corruption et également et
par la monsieur marounet avait même
poursuivi aussi le gouvernement pour des
fuites concernant des allégations aussi
de peau de vin dans ce cas-là lui aussi
avait poursuivi elle va obtenu une
dédommagement de l'État d'ailleurs et
avec le temps chercher et cherche encore
beaucoup à rétablir sa crédibilité à
redorer son image et le temps fait quand
même bien les choses le public oublie ça
me remémore au moins une chose certains
détails qui passent à des études je veux
si vous voulez et donc les politiciens
ont alors beau jeu de remettre en
évidence ce qui fait davantage leur
affaire avec le mentionné vous l'avez
dit aussi lors de votre entrevue oui il
y a eu des choses qui ont été faites par
ce gouvernement mais on a peut-être
tendance à oublier certaines coupures
qui ont été faits dès le début du mandat
je me rappelle dès la première année de
du gouvernement Charest il y avait des
manifestations qui disaient on n'a pas
voté pour ça eu les réformes en santé
aussi sans compter toutes les
allégations et en tout cas les
concernent l'éthique alors c'est normal
quand on passe sous une si mauvaise note
on essaie de refaire se refaire une
vertu et le temps permet peut-être de
faire oublier certaines aspérités si
vous voulez
Patrice je m'excuse on parle souvent de
du fait que j'encharais et mal aimé des
Québécois mais on oublie quand même de
dire qu'en 1998 il avait été défait par
Lucien Bouchard mais il avait eu il a vu
la pluralité des voix il a été lu
majoritaire largement 2003
ré-immunitaire en 2007 réélu majoritaire
en 2008 et il est passé à 4 débuter de
se faire élire en 2012 c'est quand même
pas si mal pour un policier qu'on dit si
elle détestait moi j'ai toujours
l'impression que les gens qui ne
l'aiment pas ne l'aiment pas
viscéralement mais force est de
constater qu'au Québec il y avait moyen
de trouver des gens qui apprécient
jean-charentes aussi parce que un
presque quatre mandats
par les temps qui courent au PLQ je veux
dire c'est comme loin c'est un mirage
qui est très très très loin et Monsieur
chaurant 98 je me souviens comme vous
dites bien tu me diras années où le vote
populaire est pas allé du côté qui est
du parti qui a formé le gouvernement il
revient à 10 ans dans l'entrevue moi il
y a la présomption d'innocence de notre
société je ne demande pas que
d'être privilégié par mon titre ou mon
statut d'ancien Premier ministre mais je
veux pas être en dessous donc il
redemande des excuses au gouvernement le
goût on écoute on revient
parce que un gouvernement qui représente
l'état
l'État c'est ça transforme des individus
ça transcende qui est au pouvoir à ce
moment-là doit agir de manière noble et
c'est ce que j'ai toujours essayé de
faire moi que j'étais au gouvernement et
j'étais allée circonstances je pense que
oui il devrait présenter des excuses
puis il y avait quelqu'un qui disait le
pack de présenter des excuses du pack
qui lui reste pas beaucoup de
crédibilité
très rapidement presque un oui ou non je
veux vraiment parler de poids lièvre
est-ce qu'il y aura des excuses vous
pensez Jonathan
moi je le crois qu'il va y en avoir oui
je me faisais congés je pense que ce
sera la l'issue de la chose fermée
noblement Alec
ouais peut-être vendredi à 16h mais il
va y en avoir un moment ou un autre
Hélène où est probablement mais en même
temps
sur ce qui va arriver avec le chèque
le chèque
ok monsieur poignet par où commencer je
vais vous le premier tweet de Monsieur
Poulet qui annonce sa victoire entre
guillemets dernière heure et critique
CBC est officiellement considéré comme
un média financier par le gouvernement
maintenant les gens savent que c'est de
la propagande Trudeau et non des
nouvelles signées ici pour sauver un
milliard de dollars et des financer la
CBC
monsieur Blanchet qui commande quelques
secondes après
quel est l'intention pierre pollièvre
affirme que CBC news est un média
propagande libéral radio-Canada n'est
pas exemple de tout reproche dit-il
toutefois il veut aussi couper son
financement pour les arts l'information
et le français dans les régions c'est
très grave et réponse de Radio-Canada
c'est le dernier que je vous montre
notre journaliste est impartial et
indépendant prétendre le contraire il
faut c'est pourquoi nous suspendons nos
activités sur Twitter il s'en va où avec
ça et l'indiqué c'est pas nouveau
ces charges qu'on s'ici toute la
campagne au leadership il en a parlé là
c'est quand même d'écrire à Twitter
d'exiger des trucs est-ce qu'il va
encore plus loin d'après vous oui il va
toujours un peu plus loin mais vous
l'avez dit pendant la campagne au
leadership c'était fascinant lorsqu'il
faisait des discours c'était toujours
ces phrases de lorsqu'il promettait de
définancer la CBC qui lui valait les
plus grandes ovations c'est extrêmement
populaire auprès de la base militante
conservatrice de manière générale dans
le reste du Canada c'est quand même de
bons taux de ne pas aimer CBC en partant
mais chez les conservateurs de détester
de mépriser mais CBC c'est pratiquement
une condition sinequanone pour vêtements
de ce parti alors Monsieur Poirier
ça il alimente ça ce qui est évidemment
extrêmement déplorable ici c'est qu'il y
a basculé de de dire je vais défoncer
subissi bon à la rigueur c'est légitime
c'est une position politique qui peut se
défendre si on y croit mais là de dire
que si bien ici fait de la propagande
protrudo là il a traversé une ligne à
mon avis qui est extrêmement dommageable
il vient encourager ses idées ses
perceptions complotistes qui existent
dans la population il n'est plus capable
de faire la distinction entre des
fantasmes ou de la rhétorique politique
et la réalité et je trouve
personnellement ça extrêmement
dommageable pour la démocratie c'est
indigne d'un inspirant chef Premier
ministre et j'aimerais moi entendre ces
députés québécois qui se cachent tout en
ce moment qui n'ose pas trop aller au
front pour défendre cette position parce
que par ailleurs Radio-Canada au Québec
c'est très populaire et de s'en prendre
à Radio-Canada ça passerait peut-être
pas très bien alors voilà il se cache
preuve qu'ils n'ont pas beaucoup
d'influence dans ce parti d'ailleurs il
n'a toujours pas expliqué de manière
factuelle comment il pouvait retirer un
milliard de CBC qui est une entité avec
Radio-Canada sans toucher à Radio-Canada
parce qu'il dit Radio-Canada je sais que
ça va vous passer la rampe mais CBC ça
ne va pas Alec
par quel bout commencer
pointe la maison ah je vous l'avais dit
elle était en feu cette maison c'est lui
qui a demandé à Twitter d'avoir cette
étiquette là Twitter là on s'entend il
reste 6 personnes qui travaillent là et
c'est pas eux qui décide si oui ou non
si bien ici mérite quoi que ce soit si
on regarde
juste
est-ce qu'on a l'image parce que les
gens ont pas vu l'image ou que Twitter
final financer non pas et vous savez
l'ensemble non ça c'est ça c'est
l'ancien ils l'ont changé ils l'ont
rechargement parce que si vous la
trouvez ou il continue à être désolé
qui sont en train de mettre en place
pour prévenir les utilisateurs de
certains liens entre les organisations
médiatiques puis les gouvernements quand
je dis reste à peu près 6 personnes chez
Twitter c'est qu'on a tellement sabré
chez personne qui fait des réflexions
éthiques sur qu'est-ce qui est financé
par quoi gabolief demande quelque chose
à Twitter Twitter reçoit ça regarde il y
a Polia 300000 personnes qui le suivent
doit savoir ce qu'il dit on lui donne
l'étiquette et la pierre après pour lire
vous le voyez Twitter la preuve qu'il
est d'accord avec moi
d'accord avec personne ils savent pas ce
qu'ils font actuellement ils sont mêlés
avec la
BBCS ils sont tout perdu chez Twitter
enfin que c'est pas la preuve de rien ce
qui est intéressant là-dedans c'est
parce que Twitter a décidé c'est ce que
Pierre polliath d'instrumentaliser
Twitter donc un milliardaire américain
libertariens pour attaquer une
institution canadienne qui est
effectivement peut être mal aimé chez
dans certains coins mais qui participent
quand même à la vie démocratique du pays
alors c'est comme si Pierre Poirier dit
moi je vais utiliser
confiance américaine de milliardaires
pour faire mon affaire mais faudrait pas
qu'il y ait d'autres ingérences d'un
autre pays par contre dans le processus
électoral canadien moi je trouve ça
quand même très drôle qu'on s'en remette
à une entreprise américaine pour prouver
son poids un milliardaire qui est un peu
provocateur je comprends pas vraiment ce
que pourrait investir d'aller chercher
mise à part exciter sa base je suis pas
sûr que bon ça va lui amener beaucoup
beaucoup de vote là mais justement
Jonathan sa base adore les gens
applaudissent puis ils sont contents
quand on attaque CBC mais s'il veut
augmenter sa base pour prendre le
pouvoir un jour est-ce qu'il joue pas un
jeu dangereux absolument et c'est ce à
quoi pierre pollièvre nous a habitué
depuis son exception la direction du
Parti conservateur c'est-à-dire un pas
en avant deux pas derrière des fois on
le voit faire des sorties on dit oh il
semble vouloir pas entrer dans un moule
parce que je sais que des gens vont dire
bah mon âme ça des politiciens qui sont
différents mais vouloir quand même
parler un électorat plus large
souvenez-vous ce que brain avait dit
dans sa première rencontre avec Pierre
podiev brain lui avait dit va pêcher au
milieu du poisson parle à une masse
critique de gens pas juste à ta petite
base mais chaque fois qu'on pense qu'il
fait un pas en avant et en fait deux pas
en arrière mais je vais je vais arrêter
là mon analyse Patrice qui serait
sûrement considéré comme étant très bien
aisé par Pierre polliès mais je vais
plutôt poser une question parce qu'on
dit que les faits sont têtus la vérité
tenace lorsque Monsieur polliève parle
de propagande pro Trudeau quand romain a
fait un travail d'enquête exceptionnelle
pour nous parler des millions et des
millions qui avait été donné en contrat
pour avoir des habitations aux abords du
chemin Roxane notamment des donateurs du
Parti libéral est-ce qu'il considérait
que c'est de la propagande pro Trudeau
lorsque tout le travail a été fait pour
dévoiler les millions les millions fait
en octobre en octobre de contrat à
mécaniser est-ce qu'il considère que
Radio-Canada CBC faisait de la
propagande pro Trudeau quand margottbou
au mois de décembre
omis le gouvernement dans l'embaron nous
apprenant qu'il y avait une compagnie
cellulaire canadienne qui était passé
des intérêts chinois qui avait obtenu un
contrat pour protéger les communications
de la GRC je m'en souviens on s'en était
scandalisé ensemble au panel est-ce que
Pierre pollièvre considérait que
Radio-Canada que CBC faisait de la
propagande pro Trudeau un moment donné
l'effet on leur droit la vérité doit
reprendre ses droits et c'est de la
démagogie pure et simple qui était un
poli elle fait je trouve que c'est une
démarche qui honteuse et je termine en
disant qu'elle est totalement raison où
sont les députés québécois qui je le
soupçonne ne sont pas très fiers de leur
chef en ce moment et d'ailleurs ils ne
sont pas sortis les députés québécois
mais un ancien sorti si on peut avoir
juste l'extrait d'Alain réel qui lui
comme vous savez n'est plus mais connaît
la mouvance conservatrice au Québec on
va écouter ce qu'il y avait à dire
à l'inverse
juste à CBC est unique Radio-Canada
reçoit du financement au même titre que
CBC donc ça demande à Twitter aurait dû
s'il était cohérent avec son opinion le
demander pour les deux organisations
mais on le sait pourquoi il fait pas
c'est qu'au Québec ils tentent de faire
des gains ils veulent pas s'attaquer aux
francophones à tous les milieux culturel
artistique
Hélène va falloir qu'il joue au
funambule là pour préserver Radio-Canada
attaquer ses besoins ça va être
difficile de tenir ça là j'ai bien hâte
de voir mercredi à la réunion
hebdomadaire du caucus qu'est-ce que les
Québécois vont faire pour monsieur et
madame tout le monde qui l'ignore
peut-être la certains endroits je pense
notamment ici à Ottawa
la salle des nouvelles il y a des
anglophones et des francophones qui se
côtoient alors je vois pas comment
pupitre 1 3 et 5 serait le instrument de
propagande et le pupitre 2 et 4 lui
serait un journaliste objectif ça
participe d'une campagne pour mousser la
méfiance envers les institutions et je
le répète là c'est pas digne d'un
inspirant Premier ministre très clair
vous l'avez dit c'est que la rhétorique
et les ferme en est ce mail et les mais
c'est populaire à court terme on verra
pour lui à moyen terme et à long terme
merci beaucoup à vous trois très très
agréable de vous avoir parlé aujourd'hui
à très bientôt au revoir au revoir pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI